warner bros is preparing to drop some
new info on gotham knights and xbox is
recovering from a rough weekend
when gotham knights was first announced
one of the key features revealed for the
game was co-op gameplay with the partner
player using either batgirl nightwing
red hood or robin however an updated
listing on the playstation store caused
some speculation as to whether or not
the game would be expanding that co-op
to four players instead while in a
statement to pc games n via twitter
warner bros games brand manager devin
newberry confirmed gotham knights will
quote have two-player campaign co-op as
announced previously at the time of this
recording it is unclear if four-player
network support means another mode for
gotham knights or if it was just merely
a mistake luckily there's a chance more
info will be shared tomorrow i say this
because the official gotham knights
twitter is teasing new gameplay tomorrow
tuesday may 10th featuring nightwing and
red hood this isn't the first time that
either character has appeared in a
modern batman game either after briefly
appearing in arkham city nightwing was
given a bigger starring role in arkham
knight's campaign and even received his
own downloadable mission as part of the
game's season pass red hood's
downloadable episode was similarly brief
and featured the vigilante mopping up
black masks gang after the events of
arkham knight switching gears now from
gotham struggles to xbox struggles over
the weekend the xbox network struggled
with some server issues that made some
digital games completely unplayable even
offline messages posted to the xbox
support account on twitter suggest the
outage began on may 6th when users began
reporting they were unable to launch
games on xbox consoles and via the cloud
and according to xbox support the
service resumed normally and then had
issues again fortunately all of these
issues were seemingly resolved by may
8th but the outage left fans with
questions and concerns about microsoft's
policies and needing to connect to the
internet to play non-live games paris
lilly who has worked with xbox in the
past said he hopes microsoft can be more
transparent in the future about its
digital rights management policy and
offer new solutions to avoid these types
of headaches for players in the future
as usual the outage did not affect
everyone but this was a notable event
that microsoft worked through the
weekend to fix xbox said in a subsequent
tweet that it has now seen significant
improvements for the issue and that full
mitigation of the problem will come with
the launch of a new update this week and
a collaboration happened twice because
what what's the crossover between baby
shark fans and pub g mobile fans like i
got it all right parents who play pub g
probably have some kids who are into
baby shark
but what babies or toddlers
are pulling off
head shots in between diaper changes i
just who is this for i don't get it
let me know if you have any ideas or if
you're the the perfect type of player
for this
um
and i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]